[Music]
welcome back America we're here with our
friend Ted Cruz Senator Cruz obviously
the state of Texas like Arizona New
Mexico a couple others are really badly
affected by Joe Biden's no border policy
you've got slavery sex slavery child
slavery indentured service I mean real
world modern time slavery taking place
in the United States and America that is
that that that we haven't seen since the
end of the Civil War and we have a
president of the United States who who
goes to a pkin village visit and that's
it you have a vice president of the
United States who's in charge of it she
could give a damn um what do you make of
this because it's obviously intentional
Mark you're absolutely right it it is a
catastrophe on every level it is a
humanitarian disaster it is a public
health disaster it is a public safety
disaster it's a national security
disaster and you're also right that this
is deliberate this is not caused by the
fact that Joe Biden is incompetent that
Alejandra mayorcas is negligent this is
the deliberate outcome they want when
Joe Biden became president he inherited
the lowest rate of illegal immigration
in 45 years and he deliberately broke
the system he opened the border and the
numbers immediately shot up
9.6 million illegal immigrants have
crossed into this country illegally and
and you use the word slavery you're
exactly right that's what it is you may
recall the last time Alejandra mayorcas
testified in front of the Judiciary
Committee where where I put up a poster
board with a picture of colored
wristbands and I asked him a question I
said Mr secretary what are these colored
wristbands and you and I are both
lawyers as lawyers we we never ask a
question we don't know the answer to
I'll tell you may orc's answer blew me
away he said I have no idea what those
wristbands are I've never seen them
before and and and with complete shock I
said to him I said Mr secretary you have
just told the American people you are
utterly incompetent at your job and you
don't give a damn enough to even pretend
why because just about every illegal
alien that crosses this country is
wearing one of these colored wristbands
they're colorcoded for how many
thousands of dollars they owe the
cartels if you stand on the B banks of
the real Grand River you see hundreds of
those wristbands laying in the grass and
what happens they turn themselves into
the border of Patrol and Joe Biden sends
them to every city in America America
and the teenage boys when they get there
they're working for the cartels they're
committing crimes they're robbing cars
they're robbing houses they're mugging
people because they have to pay back the
money and even worse Mark the teenage
girls thousands upon thousands of them
get trapped in sex slavery where they
have to pay off the cartels and they can
be trapped for years in forced
prostitution these colored wristbands
are quite literally modern-day leg irons
and Joe Biden and KLA Paris and the
Washington Democrats they do not care
and they want this to continue it is so
abhorent to me what the Democrat Party
was and is and they like to lecture us
about civil rights they like to lecture
us about um uh we conservatives need to
be more moderate and they go on and on
and on about this stuff and yet they
continually create these disasters and
this going on on the southern border inh
Humanity on both sides of the Border in
the United States Ates fentol my buddy
Rick Harrison's son just passed away
Adam from an overdose of of fentol it's
happening all over the
country you even have Democrat Mayors
complaining about what's going on but
they attack Greg Abbott they don't
attack of course Joe Biden but my
question to you is this you came out
with other constitutional conservative
Senators you and they are very angry
about the Republican leadership in the
Senate you're very angry about the deal
that they're trying to cut with Schumer
they've cut out the speaker of the house
and the Republican leaders in the house
what the hell is going on with them look
this is a lousy deal it's a deal that
that was negotiated with Chuck Schumer
and it's designed not to secure the
Border in my view we ought to use the
leverage we have to try to force this
Administration to follow the law but but
Schumer and the Democrats don't want to
do it and unfortunately Republican
leadership they're like Charlie Brown
with Lucy in the football although this
time it's it's Lucy Schumer and and
every time they run to kick it and Lucy
Schumer pulls the ball away and and and
Republican leadership never seems to
learn you look at this bill we actually
don't know what's in the bill because
they won't show us statutory text which
tells you how bad it is but we do know
the bullet points they put out on the
bullet points they essentially normalize
5,000 illegal immigrants a day 5,000 a
day that works out to over 1.8 million
illegal immigrants a year that is
ridiculous and yet that that that's
where Republican leadership is I think
we should use our leverage to say fix
the problem now I'm constantly perplexed
by the Republicans in the Senate I'm
constantly per perplexed you look at the
house we have the opposite we have
constant upheaval Y and constant removal
of the leadership you're look in the
Senate you haven't had a new leader in
15 16
years McConnell is the longest serving
leader of either party yep he has no
ability to communicate to the American
people he doesn't care that he has no
people he controls the levers of power
within the Senate he controls the
fundraising so he tries to pick off
certain people in primaries and support
other people so he has people elected
who are supportive of him this this is
like the old Smoke Filled back rooms of
the past this is not transparency and
Republicans and conservatives and the
nation suffer as a result of this no
look you're exactly right I I I think it
is time for Mitch McConnell to go I
helped lead the fight to try to defeat
Mitch McConnell we ended up when I made
a motion to delay leadership election so
we could debate the direction of of the
conference I got 16 votes I I needed 25
so I was nine votes short so that's
encouraging those are the first 16 votes
that have been cast against Mitch but he
still has control on the conference and
you're right one of the ways holds on to
control is W is with money if you oppose
him he zeros you out so my last
re-election 6 years ago was at the time
it was the most expensive Senate race in
US history I was out spent 3 to one and
I ended up winning by less than three
points Mitch McConnell spent $300
million Nationwide in Senate races you
know how much he spent in Texas zero not
one penny I'm right now as you know in a
very tough re-election race in Texas the
Democrats Chuck Schumer has made clear
I'm his number one target the Democrats
intend to spend over $ hundred million
to defeat me in Texas we just had a poll
last week that showed it as a onepoint
race and yet we can expect Mitch again
not to spend any money to defend me
which means the the only way that we
hold on is if the folks watching this
show go to tedcruz.org right now go
online to tedcruz.org make a
contribution of 510 2550 100 bucks
because my race my support is not from
the big money special interest in
Washington DC it it it is from
constitutional conservatives across the
country who go to Ted cru.org and and
and who help give me the resources to
withstand a100 million from these
left-wing Democrats and marxists who are
trying to invade this country and
destroy this country hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fo
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else